[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à ceux qui nous font
l'honneur d'écouter
bonjour à vous federica et jimmy et
bonjour à vous gabriel jean marie vous
êtes porte parole de combat ouvrier un
parti politique qui participent
régulièrement aux élections municipales
depuis plusieurs scrutins donc en
présentant des listes des candidats
alors est-ce que vous poursuivrez la
lutte puisque vous êtes un parti
politique je dirais avec des convictions
sociales vous rappelle que vous êtes par
ailleurs secrétaire général de d'un
syndicat du plus important syndicat de
l'île la la la cgt m alors est-ce que
vous poursuivrez votre lutte à combat
ouvrier sous cette forme encore de
participation aux élections municipales
en mars 2020 gabriel jean marie petite
précision je suis ici en tant que papa
de combat ouvrier pas en tant que
secrétaire général de la cgt on je je
n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que vous étiez
je tiens à préciser vous êtes parent et
bien oui mais mais vous êtes secrétaire
général de la cgt ça c'est en fait je
suis ici en tant que porte parole de
combat ouvrier
par ailleurs vous êtes secrétaire
générale de la cgtm gabriel jean marie
je vois en vidéo et je confirme et va
participer aux élections en mars 2020 et
je confirme donc combat ouvrier
présentera une liste comme en 2014 à
fort de france
c'est tout ça s'arrête là la
participation s'arrête là alors
justement quel est l'intérêt pour
d'abord pour vous vous vous présentez à
fort de france avec la conviction à 100%
que effectivement votre liste sera
gagnante ou que vous aller conquérir la
municipalité foyalaise je ne sais pas ce
que vous entendez par gagnante en tout
cas nous notre démarche c'est de porter
de lever ce que nous appelons le drapeau
du communisme révolutionnaire parce que
nous serons la seule liste je dis bien
la seule à défendre ses positions c'est
à dire à dire que les travailleurs les
la situation peut changer si les
travailleurs s'impliquent
si les travailleurs défendre leurs
propres intérêts nous tenons à le dire
alors quel est l'intérêt pour les
citoyens de martinique de vous voir
participer à ces élections et et
notamment donc à fort de france alors
vous me posez la question évidemment
gagner gagner
gagner c'est on y va sélection principe
c'est pour gagner donc aux municipales
c'est pour obtenir la majorité pour
pouvoir gérer les affaires d'une ville
va tout casser ça en principe entre le
classique en tout cas en tout cas nous
n'y allons pas pour gérer un peu comme
ça se passe à la cité m ou dans
certaines municipalités pour gérer dans
l'intérêt des possédants nous y allons
comme je les dis c'est pour défendre des
intérêts les idées communistes parce que
ce sont des idées qui n'ont qu'on entend
plus aujourd'hui et nous y allons pas ce
que nous disons que le monde du travail
n'est pas représenté dans les assemblées
est ce que notre participation voire
même si nous avons des listes des
candidats dans ces municipalités ou dans
cette municipalité ça va changer les
choses
nous sommes très clair dès le départ
nous le disons nous y allons pour
défendre des intérêts nous avons un
programme très clair notre programme
mais sur le programme communiste nous
disons par exemple l'interdiction des
licenciements nous allons défendre cette
idée tout comme nous allons aussi dire
que il faut que le les comptes des
entreprises soient accessibles aux
salariés
c'est une chose aussi tout comme nous
disons que nous défendons un smic qui ne
soit pas inférieure à 1800 euros net
alors du coup c'est pas en rapport
direct avec les affaires municipales
salah ben oui monsieur parce que dans
les municipalités dans la ville de fort
de france comme ailleurs mais il y à de
nombreux travailleurs qui affronte qui
font face à de nombreuses difficultés et
je termine en disant qu' il y a pas
exemple un point qui fait l'actualité
ces jours ci c'est la question de la
chlordécone
ben oui nous irons pour dire que ce sont
ceux qui en ont profité ce qui ont
commercialisé ce qu'ils ont produit ce
que cette molécule qui doivent payer
c'est à dire tous les riches payent
notamment les békés qui ont amassé des
fortunes là dessus donc la campagne
électorale des municipales c'est
davantage une tribune d'expression pour
vous sur des problèmes sociétaux que des
programmes pour la gestion d'une vie
c'est l'actualité monsieur c'est
l'actualité je n'en disconviens pas mais
je vous dis que du coup vous allez aux
élections pas avec un programme de
gestion municipale pour fort-de-france
nous n'allons pas pour gérer les
affaires des possédants de la
bourgeoisie nous y allons pour défendre
et pour exposer les problèmes concrets
de là la grande majorité de la
population avec qui en figure 2
puisque jusque là c'était ghislaine jeu
acharné qui était d'ailleurs elle aussi
par ailleurs comment dirais-je à la
direction de combat ouvrier mais qui
était aussi secrétaire général de la cgt
m
donc même même profit le même parcours
elle n'est plus secrétaire générale de
la cgtm c'est vous vous vous êtes porte
parole ce matin de combat ouvrier donc
est ce que c'est vous qui serait tête de
liste gabriel jean marie pour l'élection
municipale à fort de france
à la campagne la campagne alors je vais
vous dire ça sera soit un homme soit une
femme ça je peux vous le dire oui
forcément
jusqu'à la parité donc ça sera soit un
homme soit une femme mais maintenant et
c'est encore décidé aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas encore décidé nous sommes
dans nos si la réflexion
alors ce jeu je prolonge un peu ma
question précédente parce que pour vous
à combat ouvrier c'était le cas aussi
lors des précédentes participations aux
campagnes électorales
c'est un peu je le disais à une tribune
et la poursuite alors sous une autre
forme
pourquoi pas en profitant justement de
cette tribune électorale
c'est toujours pour vous exprimer
enfoncer le clou parce que vous êtes
toujours vent debout contre le
gouvernement le gouvernement actuel et
la politique de l'actuel président la
république
emmanuel macron vous dites il faut
riposter contre les coups bas du
gouvernement c'est un peu votre slogan
oui mais le gouvernement n'est que
quelque chose qui cache autre chose le
reflet le gouvernement n'est là que pour
porter la politique d'un groupe de d'une
catégorie plus importantes c'est-à-dire
le patronat ce que nous appelons les
capitalistes c'est à dire ceux qui
possèdent réellement et qui gouverne je
faisais remarquer il n'y a pas longtemps
que le medef a l'habitude de se réunir
dans une ville qui s'appelle jouy en
josas dans les yvelines et régulièrement
ils disent qu'ils invitent les membres
du gouvernement ils ne les invite pas
ils les convoquent et ils donnent leur
appréciation et leurs instructions au
gouvernement
et lorsque vous prenez la politique de
monsieur macron bien c'est exactement ce
qui se passe quand vous prenez la loi
travail que vous preniez les ordonnances
que vous preniez toute cette disposition
la retraite les allocations chômage ce
ne sont ni plus ni moins ce qu des
desiderata les injonctions du medef qui
sont mises en application alors
concernant la plus globalement vous
allez présenter une liste à fort de
france mais la gestion des municipalités
des communautés d'agglomération
en martinique singulièrement comment
quelqu'un quel regard qu'elle analyse
vous portez sur la gestion globale est
ce que vous trouvez que finalement c'est
ce sont des questions qui sont sociales
en faveur justement des catégories les
plus défavorisées de écoutez c'est que
c'est que l'activité que sont les
communautés d'agglomération fonctionne
comme les communes et lever les voiles
ni plus ni moins fonctionne avec les
subventions avec l'argent public donc de
la même manière qu'il n'y a peu de
moyens pour faire fonctionner
correctement les municipalités ben les
communautés d'agglomération gère la
pénurie et c'est pour cette raison qu'on
voit qu'il ya certaines de souvent
d'ailleurs des augmentations de taxes
d'impôts et on a pu voir par exemple
dans le sud
ben il ya eu des mobilisations et les
collectivités de l'agglomération encore
une fois n'échappe pas n'échappe pas aux
restrictions imposées par le
gouvernement
gouvernement qui lui même appliqué les
instructions du patronat donc là encore
c'est le système qui se répliquent sur
ces collectivités là et donc en fait
pour qu'elles changent il faut changer
le système quoi il faut changer s'il
faut changer ce système il faudrait que
vous selon selon moi mais selon aussi
beaucoup de personnes et de plus en plus
parce que effectivement les dispositions
qui sont prises vont à l'encontre de
l'intérêt de la majorité de la
population
gardiens jean marie on arrive au terme
de notre entretien
comme vous combat ouvrier martinique et
en guadeloupe parce que vous êtes très
lié avec eux votre pendant de guadeloupe
1 et jean marie nomertin justement le
principal responsable de combat ouvrier
guadeloupe vous êtes tous les deux
membres de l'union communiste
international si je ne me trompe pas et
on termine là dessus sur ce qui se passe
en depuis quelques temps en amérique du
sud et notamment avec la démission toute
récente du d'evo morales dont certains
disaient qu'ils avaient fraudé aux
dernières élections présidentielles dans
d'autres disent qu'il est victime d'un
coup d'état orchestrée notamment par les
états unis et ses alliés
enfin et puis à d'autres pays là qui
sont en proie notamment le monde pense
qu au venezuela donc votre regard pour
conclure mon regard pour conclure c'est
de dire que et il n'y a pas qu'en
bolivie
ce toute la planète il n'aura échappé à
personne et notamment à vous le
journaliste averti que ça bouge de hong
kong jusqu'en bolivie en passant par
l'argentine le liban l'irak et qu'il y a
effectivement que des populations sur
les votes alors s'agissant de la bolivie
puisque vous m'avez posé la question
belle amérique du sud on je la mets du
sud etc latine le brésil l'argentine
enfin tout ça le chili ne l'oublions pas
je vais techniquement il ya une
situation très dure
ben je veux dire qu' il faudrait que
cette situation se répète sur toute la
planète
parce que effectivement il faudrait que
ceux qui subissent bain se révoltent et
se bougent de manière à effectivement
éjecté certain nombre de parasites
installés notamment par les pays
impérialistes tels que les états unis et
des pays d'europe
merci gabriel son mari d'avoir participé
à ce 5 à 10 bonne journée à vous tous et
avoue tout
bonjour nyan cat
[Musique]